the beach bum you did this movie with
Matthew McConaughey I did Snoop Dogg
correct this is a I'm gonna say a chill
cast everybody sort of was stoned for a
lot of it and I don't smoke part well
the you don't smoke pot no I don't and I
felt and I had to sort of smooch them so
I felt like I kind of got a contact high
and was kind of stone from smooching
them which was not my idea of fun
sorry did you have a kissing scene with
Snoop Dogg cuz when he has come here and
Andy you'll back me up on this when
Snoop Dogg visits our show which he's
done many times he and his entourage
hang out in the dressing rooms
everyone's smoking and it gets into the
filtration system and I've come out and
the audience is laughing and the show
doesn't start from there ten minutes now
we actually rent a trailer yeah keep him
off premises we honey right that sounds
like a joke but so that the audience
doesn't get stoned we have a trailer I
believe a Snoop Dogg I shot a movie with
him I can testify it's a it's a lot it's
going on we have a clip here from the
beach bum tell us about the scene I
think you're talking about Matthew
McConaughey's character here is that
right I have not seen this clip I was
busy producing sperm
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well anyway I think this is a scene we
are talking to is it your daughter and
yes I think I'm doing all the heavy
lifting here and it's called the beach
bum which you don't even know take a
look I almost ruined the whole day don't
say that no it was fun he's that mom
it's just moved on tell me the excuses
for her you just kind of have to accept
that he's from another dimension he
really is and you have to love him for
it I do you and limp-dick we're gonna
have to accept that no but I do think
Moondogs mother collagen way too much
I've told her this before I mean he wore
a diaper until he was eight honestly I
think she put brandy in his little
bottle
the beach bum is in theaters nationwide
starting Friday March 29th isla Fisher
will be right back